students in Nashville Tennessee the site
of a recent horrifying Mass school
shooting walked out rallied and marched
yesterday for stricter gun safety laws
for any gun safety laws and of course we
are yet again of mass shootings that
essentially no other country has and
then we immediately say some of us say
we have to do something and Republicans
block the idea of doing anything and
next thing you know we've moved on and
it's the next mass shooting a couple of
Articles to look at chalk beat Tennessee
reports Nashville students rally for
tougher gun laws as Governor seeks armed
guards for every school some say arm the
teachers maybe arm the students right I
mean how far are we going to go more
than a thousand Nashville area students
walked out of school on Monday
converging outside the Tennessee State
Capitol to demand stronger gun laws
after last week's mass shooting at a
small private school in the city
this started at 10 13 a.m it was a week
since Nashville police received that
first call about the shooter at the
Covenant School three children and three
adult staff members were killed we have
a little more information about the
shooting The Tennessean reports students
demand gun control shooter fired 152
rounds in about a 14 minute incident and
of course that has to have something to
do with the guns employed you're not
going to do that with a handgun and so
those who say this has nothing to do
with Guns by literal definition
can't possibly be correct now I think
it's important to contextualize all of
these events I mean think of it a week
ago
shooting in Nashville
six dead three kids three adults rallies
marches demands for gun safety
Republicans saying arm the teachers and
put armed guards in school but meanwhile
in this week how many mass shootings
have there been how many mass shootings
have there been just in the last week
because yesterday there was one in
Baltimore and I'm looking at my list
here and of course it's very hard to
keep up because there are so many
yesterday a mass shooting in Baltimore
and then also one in Mesa Arizona
and there was a mass shooting yesterday
in Hampton Virginia another one on
Sunday in Petersburg Virginia the point
is just in the intervening time between
the Nashville shooting and today and we
follow all of the lives affected
everything that's taken place all of the
discourse and discourse may be a bit of
a generous term in some of these cases
we follow all of it
there have been so many mass shootings
since most of which you and I haven't
heard of unless we went out looking for
that information and so this really is
an epidemic
we continue to see one side that says
don't do anything about guns and then we
see our side say Hey listen
there are things we can try and again I
outlined last week my 10-point plan for
things that we could try but there is an
entrance intransigence and a
recalcitrance uh to this discussion and
among half of those who could be part of
the solution here and so it's a great
thing with the students in Nashville did
and I continue to hope that we can do
something we can't give up as I said
last week although it would be logical
to think maybe maybe we should what else
can we do we've tried everything to
convince these people that it's worth at
least trying some gun safety but we
really can't give up because otherwise
people will continue to die so good for
the students in Nashville Tennessee and
of course we will follow whether any
change does take place